IN 1992, BILL CLINTON WAS
RUNNING FOR THE WHITE HOUSE.
WITNY HOUSTON STARRED IN THE
BODY GUARD, TAYLOR SWIFT WAS 3
YEARS OLD.
AND EMBRYOS WERE FROZEN.
THAT MADE HISTORY FOR ONE FAMILY
TODAY.
AND DR. SANJAY GUPTA IS GOING TO
SHOW US THEIR JOURNEY.
>> Reporter: IN APRIL OF 1992,
MORE THAN 30 YEARS AGO, THE
WORLD WAS DIFFERENT.
BILL CLINTON WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
PHONES LOOKED LIKE THIS.
I WAS 23 YEARS OLD.
AND AT A SMALL CLINIC THESE
EMBRYOS WERE FROZEN.
SUSPENDED IN TIME AT NEARLY 200
DEGREES BELOW ZERO.
WAITING PATIENTLY AT THE
NATIONAL EMBRYO DONATION CENTER
IN KNOXVILLE, TENNESSEE.
THAT IS UNTIL A FEW WEEKS AGO,
WHEN TWINS TIMOTHY AND LYDIA
WERE BORN TO RACHEL AND PHILLIP
RIDGEWAY OF OREGON.
>> WHEN WE HEARD ABOUT EMBRYO
ADOPTION WE THOUGHT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE WOULD LIKE TO DO
AND ABLE TO DO.
>> ADOPTION REFERS TO LIVING
CHILDREN AND IT'S A LEGAL
PROCESS BY WHICH A PARENT/CHILD
RELATIONSHIP IS CREATED WHEN IT
DID NOT PREVIOUSLY EXIST.
>> Reporter: DR. CLIPSTEIN IS A
FERTILITY SPECIALIST IN CHICAGO
AND CHAIRS THE ETHICS COMMITTEE.
SHE WAS NOT INVOLVED IN THE
RIDGEWAY'S CASE.
>> EMBRYO DONATION IS A
PROCEDURE IN WHICH WE TAKE
EMBRYOS FROM ONE COUPLE OR
INDIVIDUAL AND TRANSFER THEM TO
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL OR FAMILY TO
BUILD FAMILIES.
>> Reporter: FREEZING EMBRYOS IS
NOT A NEW TECHNIQUE, THE FIRST
BABY BORN FROM A FROZEN EMBRYO
WAS IN 1984.
BUT AT A TIME WHEN THE
BOUNDARIES OF LIFE HAVE BEEN
PUSHED, A NEW QUESTION HAS
ARISEN, HOW LATE IS TOO LATE?
>> WE WANTED TO CHOOSE CHILDREN
THAT IN OUR EYES WERE THE MOST
UNWANTED, THE MOST NEEDY.
THE ONES IN A LOT OF WAYS THAT
HAVE BEEN OVERLOOKED.
>> Reporter: INTENTIONALLY OR
NOT, THE RIDGEWAYS HAVE SET A
RECORD.
AFTER 29 YEARS AND 10 MONTHS THE
DONATED EMBRYOS ARE BELIEVED TO
BE THE OLDEST EMBRYOS EVER TO
RESULT IN A LIVE BIRTH.
>> WE WEREN'T LOOKING TO GET THE
FROZEN LONGEST IN THE WORLD, WE
WERE WAITING FOR THE ONES THAT
WERE WAITING THE LONGEST AT
NEDC.
>> Reporter: IT'S A FAITH BASED
CENTER WHO SAID THEY HAVE
FACILITATED 12,000 BIRTHS
THROUGH DONATED EMBRYOS.
AND THE NUMBER OF DONATED
EMBRYOS HAS CLIMBED FROM ABOUT
1,000 A YEAR IN 2013 TO ABOUT
2,100 IN 2020.
OF WHICH, AROUND 40% RESULT IN A
LIVE BIRTH.
>> THE DOCTOR ENHANCED MY
PICTURE, I SEE THREE OF THEM,
AND HE SAID, SO, YOU KNOW,
MULTIPLES CAN CAUSE PROBLEMS IN
PREGNANCY.
AND SO HE GOES AT THIS POINT I
WOULD RECOMMEND TRANSFERRING
TWO, PUT THE THIRD IN THE
FREEZER AND YOU CAN COME BACK
FOR IT.
SO I LOOKED BACK AT DR. GORDON
AND STARTED TO GET TEARY EYED.
I SAID NO YOU SHOWED ME A
PICTURE OF MY THREE CHILDREN, I
HAVE TO HAVE THEM ALL.
>> I FIGURED THAT --
>> Reporter: BUT DURING AN
ULTRASOUND THEY DISCOVERED THEY
WERE HAVING TWINS.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
RISK TO FREEZING EMBRYOS THAT'S
RELATED TO THE NUMBER OF YEARS
THAT THE EMBRYO IS FROZEN.
AND WE HAVE BEEN CRYO PRESERVING
EMBRYOS FOR NEARLY 40 YEARS AND
THERE'S NOT AN INCREASED RISK TO
THE BABIES OR TO THE PREGNANT
WOMEN.
WHAT MAKES THE EMBRYO A GOOD
QUALITY OFTENTIMES IS THE AGE OF
THE WOMAN AT THE TIME SHE
DONATED EGGS.
THE YOUNGER THE WOMAN, THE MORE
LIKELY THE EMBRYO IS GOING TO BE
NORMAL.
>> Reporter: FOR THE RIDGEWAYS
IT'S SOMETHING LARGER, SOMETHING
THEY VIEW AS A PERSONAL MISSION.
>> I WAS FIVE YEARS OLD WHEN GOD
GAVE LIFE TO LYDIA AND TIMOTHY.
IN A REAL SENSE THEY'RE OUR
OLDEST CHILDREN, EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE OUR SMALLEST CHILDREN.
>> Reporter: DR. SANJAY GUPTA,
CNN, REPORTING.